honey then we gonna have a good time a
dozen hands up to the sky we gonna chose
did you know you let it fade
we got a spark a little rise bled away
I'm counting down and do it starter and
again we come to play
yeah we play hard
[Music]
[Music]
like I've been walking
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning Millennials just felt like
giving a little extra you know a little
extra good more a little extra that was
beautiful wait I'm sorry to hear that
I'm just shocking myself with my vocal
abilities it's happy Friday everyone we
did it happy lover day it is indeed a
very happy Friday it is just a bright
sunny beautiful day in New York couldn't
be gloomy or it couldn't be gloomier and
last night it was if anyone was outside
during like the 10 minutes of her there
was a hurricane monsoon season monsoon
season I was stuck outside oh my god
what a waste of a good blowout a hundred
percent I got inside right before the
torrential downpour but everyone that
came into the party soaking wet I was
like are you looking for a hug it was
actually really nice everyone came into
the party stuffy wet because no one was
looking for a hug I already hate hugging
people I see like pretty often it's like
I don't feel the need time to try people
yeah I don't need to give like everyone
a hug when I see them I saw you last
week like you know it's like hey how are
you
I completely agree I was like I'm wet
yeah and I really think that handshakes
are underrated yeah and I would love a
good handshake walking to the party boom
boom boom
but until really I feel as though it's a
bigger transfer of germs and bacteria
handshake perhaps but you can wash a
hand also people want to talk about when
you hug someone like my makeup gets all
over their shades so what I try and push
my head away but then I look like so
mean
I've also never given a man a hug and
not had my hair get stuck in their beard
does that happen to you guys too I know
that's never happened that happened to
me last night it was a sari were you
hugging snatchler Thank You random
person random
who are you hugging snatch nobody with
the beard okay no it's like I go in for
a hug and as I'm pulling away like
strands in my hair get caught and like
their stubble and beard it happens to me
it like 9 out of 10 times that's why I
can't talk to boys
wow that's bad it's really annoying well
last night my best friend Dana got
engaged when there was so hard to talk
about it on the show like what he's
doing tomorrow night
I know I've known her a few weeks and I
feel like and the toasters have been
like so excited for her cuz she's really
a part of you know toast history it was
history like she's a legend girl who
made up my dooty brown our theme song
and she's saying it twice on the show
like the bravery knows no bounds and now
she's engaged and she's just so cute and
and so happy and I'm so happy for her I
don't know what she's gonna get a
wedding dress because I don't think in
America they make a child bride dresses
so I'm thinking she might have to take a
trip to China or something I'm thinking
maybe Russia totally she'll get it
online somewhere yes she'll have to
order it Alibaba Express did you see
that I was on Aliexpress yesterday
Jackie that is the most prestigious
honor there's two photos of me set like
in the same pair of sunglasses in
different colors and I guess they're
selling those sunglasses you're I've
paid about $40 for them so it's a really
good deal oh my god what a shame yeah I
mean I don't know if the quality is the
same Alibaba is like did you just call
them the Alibaba sham Express it's like
everything on there is a sham when I was
in high school I got to like Chanel
phone cases and honestly I've never felt
cooler it was really good for like a
high school kid who like just wanted a
Chanel but couldn't afford one and it
was special that's on you for buying
Chanel honestly I didn't even feel
guilty about it I was so excited to have
Chanel yeah you know I do yeah he's cool
she have expressed calm well
like anything you know yesterday was
great was love or today Dana got engaged
but there was some [ __ ] wild [ __ ]
going on it's like it's like I wrote the
song a toast to the wild lines and
everyone just went [ __ ] wild because
they wanted to be toasted too I
understand and today's your day today's
your day so we're gonna deliver the past
back stories that you need to know
before you wake up take a bite at your
morning toast we are but of course you
know this show doesn't this [ __ ] the
world would in turn the wood is interest
if I didn't tell you guys so today's
episode is brought to you by one of our
favorite brands sin bird which is a
monthly subscription service their
perfumes which is so great because you
can buy from their website like super
high-end Prada Fendi
fragrances for literally seven what is
it seven dollars and fifty cents a month
it's a subscription service because like
big bottles of perfume are pretty but
they're not useful you can't take them
with you when you travel like this makes
it so easy to have the right amount of
you itch money perfume and cologne it's
a way for you to discover new cents
without buying an entire bottle they
have more than 450 designer brands for
you to choose from you choose a perfume
you want to try they'll send you a
30-day supply so enough for the month
that's 120 sprays and if you're not sure
what type of site you're looking for you
can sort by brand by style by occasion
by season like maybe I'm looking for an
autumnal season with like a hint of
maple I don't know with our exclusive
offer for our listeners you can get 50%
off your first month today at scent bird
dot-com slash toast that's only seven
dollars and fifty cents for your first
fragrance so if you sign up start the
subscription your first thoughts will be
half off if you use a link scent bird
comm slash toast
that's SC ent the IRD comm slash toast
for you to try your first perfume or
cologne for seven dollars and fifty
cents and if you sign on you will smell
amazing and that's a hundred percent
guarantee a hundred percent I don't work
for the branch I don't know that but I
have to imagine but it also depends what
fragrance you choose right they have
good fragrances and they have you know
there's something for everyone so true
perfume is like such a personal choice
totally you want to see the craziest
things your cap doesn't have an opening
oh my god the plastic industry is
[ __ ] falling apart that is truly a
waste of water cat I'll just shoot
you're mine oh man that's hilarious yeah
I mean we're thirsty [ __ ] we have
seen today we got tea to spill when you
need to sustain it no accidents sweeties
feel I need a full opening in the cab to
drink my day just fill it well I'm gonna
run some lip gloss just in case you
let's skip it gets picked up anywhere oh
right follow me a Tokyo problem yeah
premium content Jackie oh well with the
current state of the journalism industry
I don't foresee this being picked up
because this is real journalism
overnight and we're about to hit it so
without further ado our first story
today is actually a bit of a joke
because our girl is in the news I know
and you know as someone who's constantly
grating the headlines you would think
that this is just normal for me but such
a crazy week
yeah such a crazy week and you want to
take us from the top well sure it all
started on Wednesday when I was out to
dinner with Ben's parents
and I just my phone kept blowing up on
Twitter and that's just never a good
thing you never want to be spoken about
on Twitter because there's nothing
positive that goes on on Twitter it's a
cesspool of sadness yeah so I had app it
immediately and I checked there was like
this huge threat about me and my
partnership with Samsung so I launched a
partnership with Samsung which by the
way don't get yourself a Samsung and
green texts are the new texts they
really are I'm [ __ ] getting a Samsung
so it was all about how I'm so
controversial and radioactive that they
can't believe Samsung worked with me
because I attacked viciously I ruined
hell I I went to her mom's house this is
what this person is saying as reporter
this reporter which I your reporter
because it's just so sad what lies is
reporting these days um I really I just
I can't get myself to say this person
saying because I actually will be afraid
like diarrhea or something I just what's
so crazy is that this person's
allegation is that Claudia harassed her
encouraged harassment doc saying you
know going after her family members
kicking her out of apartment etc we've
never spoken this person's name before
we've never written it online in a group
anything I will not start now and I will
not start now so but I don't know how
you can harass someone without ever
talking mentioning so in the spirit of
lin-manuel Miranda let's talk about this
person as you know my favorite one of my
favorite I've always been team Jacob
Taylor Lautner okay because I did with
the pronouns a little too confusing if I
just don't say her name
so her name is hello honor and basically
you don't have anything about her which
you most likely don't she is a reporter
and she was kind of the pioneer of our
cancellation she discovered like a
reddit thread with all these they listen
Clark yes she was the Sacajawea yeah of
our cancellation and basically what
happened was before we were
quote-unquote canceled like everyone
knew like what what was released about
us because it was all over like Gomi
threads reddit threads and I guess this
quote-unquote
reporter found the thread and published
it literally as her own she added some
commas some capital letters and took
credit for it which is like a whole
other play doesn't miss you I just can't
get into right now and it launched you
know the great cancellation of 2018 and
it was it was just that it was a
cancellation we got fired our show
pretty much yeah every single brand that
I was working with at the time dropped
me so I lost all my income I got chopped
up me agency I got job my management I
really don't wanna go into it it was a
super dark time and you know part of it
was deserved on my part I can own up to
that and ever since then as you guys
know the toasters have been on the
journey with us we've really made this
was like 18 months ago we have made like
such a conscious effort to move forward
in like a really positive way and what
was so upsetting about the whole
cancellation and I never really wanted
to get into it just because like I'm so
like devastating at the time was like
like I set out I got a phone and got on
Instagram like just to make people laugh
like they whatever I understand like
people who work in politics like that
you know what you're getting into where
there's certain industries are just like
so corrupt and like so dark but like
I've always set out with just the goal
of making people laugh like I I do stand
up I make stupid [ __ ] memes like it's
just supposed to be funny and
light-hearted and I got dragged into by
my own doing this like really ugly
Twitter world and I hurt people and I'll
never I'll never defend myself for that
because it was indefensible and I feel
like I've apologized multiple times and
if anyone ever came up to me and like
they love me but they're like I was
really even in 10 years they're like I
was really hurt by what you said I will
always apologize because I'm not ever
gonna defend those words because I was a
loser a 16 year old who thought it was
funny like to just you know yeah I just
thought it was funny like to be
controversial obviously if I grown up in
a different time period maybe ten years
later I would have understood the
gravity of my words and I had to learn
in a very public way like what you say
online can come back to haunt you and I
hope I hope for everyone's sake like me
learning that lesson very publicly like
helped you maybe you know stop shop
Thanks think before you speak so it's
now been 18 months and I've we have both
like spent 18 months like rebuilding our
business in a more ethical more positive
more joyous more inclusive way and I
feel like we've made real shots yeah
we're not perfect people but I feel
overall the toast is so positive so fun
brings so much joy to people it's so
helpful for some people like I work I go
to bed every night like feeling really
good about what I did that day 1,000%
and I can sleep at night knowing that
like I feel in a very very small like
not important way like I am making a
positive impact on the world right I'm
leaving the world slightly happier than
when I got up that morning
so this thread was just on and on about
how I don't deserve this Samsung deal
which by the way I'm just so grateful
like for Samsung for taking a chance on
on a controversial quote-unquote Steen
like that was really brave of them so I
guess because the world we live in
doesn't allow for that and people
apologize people change people evolve is
there no room for that like you make a
mistake and and then it's over like
what's the point what's the point of
anything if we're not all just trying to
get better right no no and it's like at
the end of the day like how long are we
gonna go on for this like let's let's
put it into perspective did i murder
someone what is the punishment that I'm
aware of what is the punishment that
fits my crime it's like these people
really just want me to like kill myself
like because they think that's what I
deserve that's what they're making it
seem like well that's one part of it but
the second part was the lies that Taylor
Lautner began to spew so what you did in
the wake of your cancellation when
really what we know what you were doing
I was there we were just you know trying
to get our [ __ ] together he didn't even
talk to anyone like it's so crazy these
are the allegations that she made of me
in the thread she said that when she
directed that when she wrote an article
about me I directed my army of fans to
intact her entire family I tried to get
her relatives fired I never apologized
for my tweets but in fact I doubled down
on what I said really
my facebook group that that all these
people were posting her address and I
was encouraging them quote-unquote
inciting them I was inciting people to
post her address and and her personal
information and I officiously harassed
her and her entire family for months
that's [ __ ] crazy
and then Shaylee step-by-step what she
did to us it's actually confusing
because I was reading it I was like oh
okay this girl's outlining what she did
it's just so weird because what went in
the wake of the cancellation it was it
was they were so much going on mhm and
you know I totally I definitely
understand like why a lot of like the
brands and like why our show had to
cancel us like nobody wants to be
involved in this kind of [ __ ] storm and
and and I do understand but there was so
much happening at the time that was like
so untrue but we had we we weren't in
the wrong you know and I didn't want to
come out and defend myself because I
would look like my apology was
meaningless when my apology was really
heartfelt yeah like there were real
facts
we out there were there was fake news
but like we didn't feel the need you
know to rebut everything that was being
said about us because it's like we
really just felt so badly and we didn't
want anything to take away from our
apology and you can't apologize and then
say but I didn't do that that's not true
like start qualifying it because we just
wanted the apology to resonate and start
fresh
right so there's now but wait then she
started putting up screenshots of my
alleged Facebook group me inciting
violence to her so it's important to
note that this girl works in media and
she said here are screenshots for the
Facebook group and put up two tweets
just different platforms I'm sure she
knows that I just I need Taylor Lautner
to know that they are two different
platforms yeah so some if you're gonna
work in this business you should some
guy named Chris who I'm just more than
likely gonna assume it's not my fan I
don't have many male fans um
saying that someone should find her
family members and harass them and
always possible and of course I'm eating
that at her he tweeted that at her of
course I don't condone that that's awful
no one should be harassed but I don't
understand how a random man named Chris
on Twitter is me inciting him I don't
know Chris stream I've never heard of
him I don't communicate with him so now
it's just like borderline delusional
like saying that I'm responsible for
what other people do it's beyond
delusional and then I think the cherry
on top of the delusional sundae was her
waiting for an apology from you oh my
god you've never apologized for any of
it and you know what's so crazy it's
like this reporter is like I don't know
what it is like she is obsessed with me
so this is not the first time since the
cancellation that she's tweeted about me
but I guess it was the first time that
like enough people were engaging where
it came across from right to my desk but
then I went to look she's been tweeting
about me like every time I fart it's on
her Twitter and she had one she listened
to me and this is not the person where
she demanded an apology that is so funny
I can't even I wouldn't would seriously
like if this is really like people are
taking this as serious which they are
cuz we'll get to the second half of the
story which is why we're even talking
about it
shout-out page 6 um what kind of world
do we live in like literally you could
say up is down and down is up and people
are like yes it's just it's lies and you
know what if I was just a regular
Twitter user and I came across this
threat I would be like poor Taylor
Lautner oh my god this surely dies
downhill since Twilight yeah no like I
see and you know I stayed on the show
and I really try and
like when we're just talking about
random like TV shows or just like
stories I always try and see all sides
of the story because I just think it's
important to do that and I literally
cannot get into the mindset of a person
who thinks I owe this person an apology
no it's it's so crazy
it's so parallel universe I feel like
I'm in an episode of the society it's
parallel universe especially because she
came after our sister trying to get our
sister fired hosting anti-semitic tweets
about Olivia and Olivia is a precious
gem and she's [ __ ] immunity per
cascade at all cost leave her out of
this so it's like she's detailing what I
allegedly did to her and I'm like so
confused cuz it sounds like exactly what
she did to me I tried to get her family
members fired um no actually you know
two weeks after the drama Olivia who
didn't do anything wrong still had her
job at o'the because like I said she
didn't do anything when she was
completely anderson and all that she
just a girl with a job and she's coming
for Olivia calling her a Zionist
conspiracy theorist who is still who's
still working at out like tweeting that
encouraging that maybe she shouldn't be
so she deleted that immediately I
remember when it happened I'm like it
was a really small insight into like you
know when someone says something
accidentally and it really gives you
like a look a window yeah into like mmm
interesting so I don't know how you
could call Olivia or of China's
conspiracy theories that maybe like I
don't know because we're Jewish it just
seems like a little anti-semitic to me I
don't know and she deleted the tweet
like right after it and said I'm sorry
like I didn't mean to tweet that like
it's an apology and it's like oh I know
what that's like
right I'm not hiding something I hate
when that happens it's like you're 35 I
was 16 whatever I'm not comparing but so
we weren't gonna sneak on any of this
because it's so stupid it's so stupid
it's tense but then Claudia received an
email from Paige say yesterday that I
would like to read verbatim because a
primer is interested the grammar is
interesting hi Claudia can you give me a
call or email when free we're doing a
bit about Taylor Lautner's tweets about
your alleged behavior and the behavior
of her fans following the story she
wrote
I'd also like to know what your new deal
with Samsung is okay so obviously this
is this girl's first day their stay in
journalism because first of all I want
to know about your deal from so do a lot
of people that's called breaching
contracts Sarah I can't speak to it I
want to know about your
- you like it's just I want to know
women inside of Miley Cyrus's [ __ ]
looks like so keep wondering I want to
know what happened in the elevator was
Solange and jay-z right like did she
probably send an email I wanted to hold
JonBenet she probably said in an email
to Solange and they say it's just such a
weirdly worded email and then at first I
was like oh this girl wrote it in a real
hurry because the plum hounds don't make
sense
she said Taylor Lautner's tweets and
about your alleged about your alleged
behavior and the behavior of her fans so
she copied this from somewhere else
where someone sent it to her to get the
behavior of her fans and I have to
imagine it was from Taylor Lautner
herself right and her friend to write a
story about how she feels on the
internet and her opinion by the way your
[ __ ] opinion is not news upon further
investigation we did find out that these
2/4 unquote reporters follow each other
on Instagram so then I'm like well
that's weird because the both the issue
with the pronouns and then following
them both on Instagram made me think
that they were in codes now I'll try to
be paranoid but it's definitely true no
totally it's right but by the way I hope
it's true because it's the only thing
that makes sense yeah other than this
person this reporter Sarah really think
that this is a news story right now so
someone feels some type of way so about
something so now that a random person's
Twitter thread qualifies as news and
again a Twitter thread about things that
happen eighteen months ago I thought
news was new news you know right this is
old news old news plus lies where are
your thoughts right and so Joe Claudia
shared her [ __ ] side so she reach out
to me for a statement and I'm just like
page six is so tacky it's like such a
tabloid I'm not gonna release a
statement about like my life like this
is just so frustrating cuz it's like
everyone could say what they want but
like hi this is my life like I have to
make a livelihood like I have to pay
rent like I have career goals I'm gonna
have children one day they need to go to
school like can I grow my business
without everyone coming for me like
every single day yeah apparently not sis
so I just didn't want to give a
statement to pay chips it's like so
tacky and and I could tell by the tone
of her email like she ain't give a [ __ ]
what I had to say she didn't give a [ __ ]
about your semen to be lumped in at the
bottom after she already torn me apart
she already made a list to take you down
yeah take me down she's taking the
beador down so you release your own
statement please Rita please read it an
outrageous thing happened yesterday that
I wasn't going to speak about because I
hate to give this person
attention but I just received this email
from page six so here we go
email attached you can see the craziness
for yourself as you all know last year I
was quote cancelled there was one person
who initiated and relentlessly attempted
to cancel me as a result my show was
cancelled I was fired from my job I was
dropped by every brand my agency and my
management I lost my entire livelihood
overnight this person docks my entire
family by for the first time publicly
associating my sisters and I with our
mom an association we have avoided
because it puts us in grave danger
that's also what we couldn't say the
time which was so frustrating everyone
was like they're hiding they're mad no
you know if I did ever just like you
know take a picture with my mom like
that would just end up on some Isis you
know corkboard and I'm just that's not
what I see for my life she looks like I
never got she even explained like half
of what was going on right exactly but
here we are today explaining and I feel
like after this show I'm going to make
the biggest poop like this has just been
brewing and like weighing so heavy on my
shoulders for so long like I'm [ __ ]
ready for the poop of a lifetime get me
toilet paper okay this person posted
anti Taylor Lautner posted anti-semitic
tweets aimed at encouraging the fire of
my innocent sister Olivia see tweets for
yourself aren't claudius which mentor
screenshot sign is conspiracy theory
yesterday this person tweeted a series
of disgusting lies about me and what she
alleges I did in the wake of my
cancellation this person is now accusing
me of doing exactly what she did to me
which is so delusional I didn't even
want to address it I'm now talking about
it because apparently page six considers
this person's lives newsworthy so here's
my statement I've never never uttered
this person's name publicly let alone
encouraged harassment daxing firing etc
I am NOT responsible for the post of
other people in a facebook group that I
did not own nor operate nor am i
responsible for what strangers on the
Internet tweet this person has made a
career of cancelling people and ruining
people's lives check it out
she shouldn't be so surprised that she
has so many enemies this person has said
I never apologize for my actions lie I
gave a link and that ugly video of me is
on you search my name it's the first
thing that comes up I can't get far away
from uh from that [ __ ] ugly picture
of me
I've apologized profusely for my
offensive remarks in the past and ever
since then I have made a conscious
effort to use my platform for positivity
joy and love shout out the morning toast
we go live Monday through Friday 10:30
a.m. Eastern
come through as for the apology that the
person who attempted to ruin my life but
didn't is waiting for it this is by the
way my editorializing amusement lmao in
the meantime while I have you all here
let's stop contributing to hatred on the
Internet and instead deposit something
positive and our girl is getting
teachers cleared list I have three
things to say before we move forward
because I think I think it's really
important one
please after this episode do not come
for Taylor Lautner like that is so
counterproductive to our message and
it's just gonna give her what she wants
so if you want to get involved in the
conversation please do so in a
respectful way because I just I can't
deal with that and then she's gonna be
saying things about it yeah but I will
say so far the toasters like they are
getting involved in the conversation and
they're so respectful and there
I [ __ ] love the toasters I don't know
if I said every society [ __ ] love the
tears the sweetest people alive and the
fact that they go toe-to-toe with these
like millennial journalists who like
circle-jerk each other on Twitter
sharpening their pitchforks it's just
like you are the brave yeah it's brave
season it's brave season the second
thing I had three things of course I
can't remember any of them but I want to
say that the second thing I was going to
say was no I need a pen and paper on the
show we could do in order Amazon like a
cute little pink one with like a furry
pink pen or something but maybe it'll
come back to me sorry okay it'll
probably come back to you so that was a
yes sorry it was just so frustrating to
have been writing this yesterday when we
sat on this show this morning that did
that morning and was like talking about
how why is gonna be talking about the
Amazon being completely engulfed in
flames like there's real [ __ ] happening
out there and it's like my idiotic but
Twitter drama is making headlines but
literally the biggest rainforest in the
world being engulfed in flames people's
homes these these indigenous people like
being in the middle of a huge fire
that's not news but this is that was
just like it really put into perspective
for me like how [ __ ] small the world
is like no and just stupid like
stupidity anyways
page six then came out with their
article last night which was such a
[ __ ] hack job they've actually
completely changed it now three times
three times it's it was very confusing
because at first it says disgraced
Instagram or Claudia ASHRAE and I'm like
oh [ __ ] they got a pit in my stomach
like what a great article and then the
first line is
to grab Queen Claudia ashtray see I
guess I would actually like a like a
full statement from page six Amaya Queen
or am i disgraced and if I have a
disgraced I would just like a
clarification on how I'm disgraced
because like I said I am you know just
so joyous trying to make people laugh I
feel like I do like a semi good job of
that I would just like some
clarification on I'd like some
clarification too because factually like
this show is that this show morning
toast is bigger than the morning breath
ever was you have more followers now
than you've ever had selling more
tickets you're a full-blown comedian on
an international hello Canada we send up
tour so if anything I think you're full
of grace that is so I think you're think
you aren't full of grace you think I'm
beauty and I'm grace and might I be miss
United States
I think so I think scuse me my team if
you like apply it yourself you could be
miss United Space Alliance a Miss Teen
New York I know I could get in I
actually had such a great phone
interview and then like the whole idea
of like a swimsuit competition scared me
out of ever doing it very fair but I get
been Miss New York Wow Miss Teen New
York no but then who can go on to be
Miss New York yeah it could have been
Miss United States but now he's you know
well we're at it Miss Universe now
you're just beauty and grace so cheers
so hard anyways this article really made
me upset obviously because it's like
full of lies and makes no sense for like
a narrative perspective and I'm someone
who's like I'm a history major like I
want to see facts lined up I want to see
what person ASA and what person B said
back to what person a said now what
person a said one person be said about
something else what does that do for
anyone yeah and the article was
incredibly confusing but then when you
pointed out the the connection between
Taylor Lautner and this girl from page
six it made total sense because timin
Lautner wrote this article like it
sounds like they didn't even they said
that I was fuming on Twitter I thought
it was very well-spoken honestly I had
Jackie as how Jackie edited it so
Jackie's is can never be described as
fusing
no you know actually today like this is
the closest I've ever been to yeah
because we're here doing a news show and
like the fact that we cite page six all
of the time and to see like to be behind
the scenes and know how this article
came to be and that it's so like full of
lies and makes no [ __ ] sense it's
like and nothing relevant all it talks
about is what happened 18 months ago
like they just got they just added
the sentence about the morning toast
today and Jackie they just added years
because this ran in print too and I saw
this morning they had if you read it it
makes it seem like we got fired from
oath yesterday yeah like there's no
dates on it they just added this morning
2018 so to know that like this is how
someone at page six like this is what
they consider journalism and like we
report on their news all of the time not
anymore not anymore it's because we we
really like pride ourselves on being
like truthful and honest when it comes
to news yeah and very least just saying
like things from the horse's mouth like
you released a very well-written
statement addressing every single thing
about what happened and she took chose
one power she chose one tweet out of
nine to put in her article but the
unit's the rest of the statement but you
know statements in there from Taylor
Lautner right so and the she got another
statement this morning from Taiwan uh
saying I still never apologized I just
she's never once expressed remorse says
I need to ask you do you have remorse
that you'd like to express I would be
absolutely heartbroken devastated and so
remorse so if I didn't let you know that
I have absolutely no remorse towards
this person I've made many mistakes in
my life and I'm I'm trying to be the
type of person who can own up to it I've
learned a lot from the Real Housewives
and what I've learned is that there's so
much value in being able to own your
mistakes and not enough people in this
world do that because we live in a
[ __ ] up time but I'd like to think of
myself as the type of person who knows
when I'm wrong and can apologize in and
up to it and then learn from it and I've
spent the last 18 months really
reflecting on the type of brand I want
to have the type of influencer comedian
host I want to be and like what kind of
impact I want to have on this world and
I really feel like I'm being dragged
back down into like these ten year old
drama yeah and I don't I don't want to
be no we have no remorse to express for
the things that you say we did that we
did not do but we do have things to
express for forcing us to be better
people a thousand percent forcing us to
start our own show launch our own
businesses start a comedy tour we open
credit we always say like I'm one of
those people who believes like
everything happens for a reason but when
you're in the middle of a shitstorm
you're like what the [ __ ] is the reason
but now 18 months later I totally see
like why God wanted this to happen to us
I firmly believe like being quote on
what canceled was really the best thing
that ever happened to me I grew up so
fast I learned so much and I feel like
now the impact I leave on this earth
will be vastly different than the one I
would have left before 1000%
I am so I really am so grateful so in
hindsight I realize all of this will be
happening for a reason right now I'm in
and I can't see why like I'm constant
like I'm just being dragged down like
people make mistakes cancel cancel
culture it's so [ __ ] toxic and
there's literally a handful of people
who are responsible for it and then
Taylor Lautner is one of them and I
refuse to be dragged down with her like
her literally her role at whatever job
she has is like director of trolls like
director of cancellation and I I refuse
to be a part of it you tried to cancel
me and I and I took my punishment
because it was deserved but I refuse to
be to be brought down I cannot I cannot
be cancelled and I will not be [ __ ]
canceled the end so mourning chose slide
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
if you're tuning in for the first time
the show is really funny you can follow
me on Instagram and check no problems
and we talked a lot about canceled
culture we see it for more than one
[ __ ] angle like just because a person
has a blue checkmark doesn't mean it's
real the end the end
signed your favorite Zionist conspiracy
theorists next story a bit of good news
snitch has been sitting on your hands
for thirty minutes
it's lever day lover day it's so weird
like why can't we ever have a happy day
like Dana got engaged last night lover
came out and like we were in the
pitfalls of Twitter being dragged
calling being called racists like when
you got engaged why couldn't it just be
a happy day no we had to be cancelled
like I just want joy we have we have so
much [ __ ] joy of so much joy we're
really good at just finding joy in the
moment this album this isn't even a low
moment you guys like this is so true
nothing
Chucky's this album chefs kiss chefs
[ __ ] okay I know you've only like had
12 hours to listen to it but on the
scale of Taylor Swift albums where do
you rate it you can't you can't rate
them yet because you like because you
don't know it yet I agree but like but I
would say for me my favorite Taylor
albums are Speak Now in 1989 and I would
put lover in the top three I don't know
where because like I said I've had so
much time to live with Speak Now in 1989
and understand the complexities of the
songs and the lyrics so it's up there in
top three for me okay Wow yeah me too
you know because red on initial listen
it's great so I can only imagine how
much better it's going to get once I
know the words and like all that stuff
it's also 18 songs like I need
more time than usual totally well Taylor
posted when lover came out she said this
album is very much a celebration of love
in all its complexity coziness and chaos
it's the first album of mine that I've
ever owned and I couldn't be more proud
I'm so excited that lover is out now
I'm so proud too it's just such a great
song there's so many different types of
songs so I mean if the songs give me
like 80s bops like I thought that about
the archer and then also um whatever
some of the songs they just give me like
hearken back to like it feels if we are
strong honey I think of that song that
scene in 13 going on 30
interesting so many of the songs give me
that I don't know what type of how to
describe that genre of songs but it's
like pop eighties anthems love it like
with snapped
I don't know Jack Antonoff definitely
like you know it's like this synth yeah
I can't just sing that word since the
album has just so many levels to it so
many layers it's like an ogre it's like
an onion
aren't there any standout songs right
now that you would encourage people to
listen to if they don't have time for 18
songs today the man let's pick five
Margot oh man
London boy Cornelia Street Cornelia
Street paper rings shame you'll get
better soon you'll get better I like to
personally cruel summer yeah yeah it's
great - yeah there's just so many but
what's so funny is we were talking about
on the toast last week in it when she
released the setlist what we thought
not the setlist the album tracklist what
we thought all the songs were gonna be
about and there was a song called paper
rings and jag and I immediately rolled
our eyes and it turns out it's exactly
what we predicted it was gonna be like
rich people being like I can 14-karat
ring but I'll take a paper one instead
no like we need that you can get a 10
carat ring just got a girl we also need
you to get a 10 carat ring so like we
have goals yeah for our Pinterest boards
exactly but she there's been a lot of
speculation about people thinking like
during her big break like her and Joe
got married or at least engaged but she
said in her lover lounge YouTube live
yesterday she's like I do you want to
get married some day she just like said
it in passing so unfortunately it's
looking like she's not married she
didn't say that is she did no I watched
the whole thing she was reading her
diary and she I know you're Ryan in the
diary she was like I don't think I'm
ever gonna get married someday and then
she kind of laughed and then just kept
reading so she didn't talk right it was
from that I the fact I stand corrected
yes she work at page six I should use
someone like you over there they
actually didn't hire me sir oh yeah
we're gonna she had an interview there
imagine imagine hello I really haven't
hurries and ladies so are there any
interesting factoids in the album so far
like any hidden messages to things she's
saying I asked you guys this there's a
song called the first one I forgot you
existed and I listened to it and it was
savage and I didn't know who it was
about and you told me it's probably
about Calvin Harris and to me that's
really one of the only songs it's like
super savagery which I'm glad she's
moving like like it I don't look for
that from her anymore she's she's
involved she's so much more mature now
she's in a long-distance long-term
relationship I don't feel the need to
like be able to decode like who this
mean tweet is about no but it is fun to
do but also she started the album with
that song what do you think that means I
mean something well because it's the
it's the first song from reputation and
I think that everyone was really shocked
that there was not one song about Calvin
Harris on reputation because that's the
era that preceded the Calvin Harris
relationship so I think that it was
closing the book on that right like so
there were so many questions about the
relationship and we never really got
full closure on it and I'm such an
interesting relationship because to me
when I was in it I thought it was her
best one it really normalized her so
much like she's always been this like
larger-than-life girl but like here she
was you know taking her jet with him to
go see him at omnia and Vegas like
that's what I would do if I was Taylor
Swift and the way it ended was so bad
and like with all the tweets saying he
was a beard it was so weird like I'm
glad she addressed it in a way that was
like please I don't think about you
enough to write a song about you because
I I don't I don't think that
relationship was like good for her now
looking back yeah I loved it when it was
happening
and it's also just a good way to
transition from your reputation into
lover she couldn't just go from like
barren to happy-go-lucky she needed
something to somewhat like bring you in
and that's kind of what it did
okay now the Dixie Chicks collab do the
Dixie Chicks sing it all they're just
organized and I think they play the play
which I'm glad because I feel like it's
a really important song to her so when I
saw that it was them on it I was like I
feel like why are you letting them tell
you about me he's struggling again with
the rest Kaiser I've listened to the
song something really annoying happened
to me and I have like music OCD about
albums like I said yesterday even when I
download them illegally like I had to
put on all the information and when I
listen to an album I want to listen to
every single song as the artist intended
and I realize I put
when I started getting ready this
morning and then I realized it was on
shuffle Jackie I had the same experience
on at Apple music Spotify oh I couldn't
figure out how to get it all shuffle on
Apple music oh my god I was so annoyed
like and so now I have to listen to it
all exactly if I didn't listen to it but
I did hear this song about her mom being
sick at first I was like why was she in
the hospital what's an orange bottle is
she pregnant and then I realized hello
but there was just one lick in there
that really shook me because she said
like when people are so desperate like
the only thing they can do is pray so I
pray to you Jesus and she said that
weird Jesus and I just never thought of
her like in a religious way like
obviously everyone is born like with
their religion but I don't never heard
of literally say the word Jesus and it
really like shook me I'm like you're not
Jewish like I just you know I mean yeah
no I agree I think and these days like
being so openly religious is not like
it's kind of polarizing for people yeah
so what I think it was an interesting
news hi she ate it and I think it that's
I love Christian music oh my god that
wine is so relatable like sometimes like
you're in such a bad situation like you
feel so helpless literally the only
thing you can do is pray yeah that's
what guys for total it's like if you
read in the Bible he like when they were
going through the desert and they only
prayed to him when they were like
suffering he was like no the time that's
why I'm here right that's the point yeah
also two of her songs she talks about
with being in school did you pick up on
that heartbreak Prince yeah and the
other one I can't remember I worked out
when I girls i love heartbreak prince
there was this song that was reminding
me of the society because it was like
all this high school drama that you
think is real life I think it's
Americana Queen there's a change there's
- I just I can't remember what they
whispered on the Hoban she's a bad bad
girl yeah it's so good and when I saw
that when I saw that name on the
tracklist I'm like that song is got a
[ __ ] slap yeah Americana Queen and
the heartbreak Prince and she rhymes
this with Prince I can't yeah she she
did an amazing job like it's so much
better than I even thought it could be
meet you and you know what I feel like I
feel validated because Ben was like
coming after me like with the four songs
she released before and not that the
four songs are bad in any way that
they're they're really beautiful but she
always saves the best for the album like
when you think of all of her lead
singles from other albums it's like not
making runs we aren't having a getting
back together 22 it's like no the real
gems of red are all too well
grace like you you can't let her her
state of grace as a single whatever you
can't let her herd lead singles like
they they mislead you sometimes
so then was listen to the album he was
coming for Taylor Swift last week when
we were in New Jersey me like gorgeous
boots own the archers the best song that
I've heard so far well also the second
school would it's nice to have a friend
which sounds exactly I could bake little
wise intro it sounds like how the gal
it's well yeah but it really it to me it
sounded like someone was friend-zoned
and so it's like it's I guess it's nice
to have a friend
no I it was about school just saying
well so Ben fell asleep what were you
listening to the album and he was like
this amazing so I was I'm really proud
of Taylor for changing hearts and
changing months every were unique in
that how was her lover session um it was
good she's oh she's taking a lover no
she didn't unfortunately I'm sure kiddo
lava she's saying the Archer acoustic he
has really Brandon showed like her
sister did she say that she recorded
this album in 'loverville no she did him
but she did - she was shopping for a new
fragrance for love oh okay I hope she
finds on its scent I hope she finds what
she's looking for - toaster size chosen
she'll sign on each and she will smell
amazing because there's only one way to
smell to smell when you sign on it's
amazing
okay this next story a straight from the
horse's mouth Miley Cyrus trip to
Twitter yesterday to discuss her
dissolution of her marriage with Liam
and you know what she's viewing some
facts and she's changing some hearts and
minds no mainly mine what do you feel
about that basically like I'm so over
the story when I started no oh my god
these tweets she's coming with some
facts and living celebrities not
releasing statements and [ __ ] going
to Twitter no or whether it's Instagram
whether it's no screenshot however you
want to do it I want it straight from
the horse's now not from your mouth to
your publicists watered down to People
magazine taking their quote and then us
reading it on the toast it's not gonna
work for me anymore like no not a and
gentlemen and Miley Cyrus tweets I can
accept that the life I've chosen means I
must live completely open and
transparent with my fans who I love and
the public 100% of the time what I
cannot accept is being told I'm lying to
cover up a crime I haven't committed I
have nothing to hide it is no secret
that I was into partying in my teens and
early 20s I have not only smokes but
advocated for weed I beg experimented
with drugs
my biggest sign to date is about dancing
on Molly and snorting lines in the
bathroom
I [ __ ] up and cheated in relationships
when I was young justice for Justin
remember him know her guitar player yeah
well I forgot about it I don't know if
she cheated on him but like that's what
she was yeah that's what she's referring
to and maybe a picture this
I lost a massive Walmart deal at 17 for
ripping a bong who knew that bong Limor
when that insecure salvia salvia went
[ __ ] wild and then Michael Phelps did
the same thing instead it was salvia -
it was like the tread back that I'm
assuming now it wasn't salvia but you
can say is legal but in college my
freshman year roommate smoke salvia and
I was like a way salvia pump it up
though Cardenas that reminds me really
quickly the idea that I have for a
patron episode that I texted you about
this morning I think in actually really
quote since so many people listen to us
in the car if we did like an hour like a
radio show if we picked songs that we
like to thought people would wanna
listen to and then talk about them
before that's cool
is that a cool idea okay sorry on
YouTube it's a good radio show I don't
listening to you right now but then we
talk about it like throughout each song
maybe that could be like a month a
installment so like we people who are on
long road trips they want to listen to
the toast and listen to music
that's it really quickly hm we don't
have to worry about copyright because
we're not like using it with like
advertisers 100% I love that idea let us
know what you think patreon.com/scishow
morning toast 1111 make a wish I wish
that journalists will get their [ __ ]
together so that we can be reporting
real news here here here here here let
me continue my early statement I got
kicked off Hotel Transylvania for buying
Liam a penis cake for his birthday and
licking it no I knew that I swung on a
wrecking ball naked there are probably
more nudes of me on the Internet than
maybe any woman in history but the truth
is once Liam and I reconciled I meant it
and I was committed there are no secrets
to uncover here I've learned from every
experience in my life I'm not perfect I
don't want to be it's boring I've grown
up in front of you but the bottom line
is I have grown up I can admit to a lot
of things but I have refused to admit
that my marriage ended because of
cheating Liam and I have been together
for decades by the way that also means
that he didn't cheat on her
yeah Liam and I have been together for a
decade I've said it before and it
remains true I love Liam and always will
but at this point I had to make a
healthy decision for myself to leave a
previous life behind I'm the healthiest
and happiest I've been in a long time
you can you can say I'm a twerking pot
smoking foul-mouthed hillbilly but I am
NOT a lot
I am proud to say I am simply in a
different place from where I was when I
was younger okay interesting actually
here we never said that we thought she
cheated because I think there was
something that when she described her
relationship there was like an open
situation anyway so it didn't even I
never thought she said I love it and I
didn't know that that was the narrative
that she got from the media I'm glad she
addressed it but I just was under the
understanding that they're just so
[ __ ] different like yeah it was never
gonna work out but from this I'm also
getting like yes they're different and
they're growing apart but she's in a
good place it's not like she's going
crazy right and Liam couldn't take it
like she's back on salvia she's her
cells like she's growing up and they're
just growing differently
agreed and so I'm really glad she
addressed it there's just something to
be said it's so understated about just
like directly addressing on your own
platform like what's going on about your
own life I feel like Hollywood is like
this is structured like [ __ ] like
warp we're in order to get something out
there it goes - like a million publicist
and a million publications and it gets
so watered down it's like no talk to
your fans that's who you really care
about and you want to change a narrative
on something [ __ ] tweet it I think
it's so like brave and it's putting
idiot reporters out of business no and
like for me now the book is closed on
this me too and this happens all the
time when people speak out on what's
going on James Charles yeah you know
once I hear it from the person like they
explain their side whether or not
they're completely in the right or wrong
it doesn't matter it's like oh okay
you're a person you're going through
something not everything is what it
seems oh my god let's move on I couldn't
agree more and literally like I think of
the James Charles incident so much in
like how I want to move forward in my
brand because I remember being like [ __ ]
James Charles like I was a pitch burger
like and I loved him I had marched like
I was so upset and that I really
believed everything talked he said I'm
like I can't imagine what James Charles
could say that would make me change my
mind and then he came out with this
video that was so just like well-spoken
thoughtful receipts he owned his [ __ ]
but also like what went on the line thin
slice yeah went through the life and I
feel like that really heavily influenced
me and like how I want to move forward
because it was so brilliant and I don't
think he did it in a brilliant PR but I
think he did it because he just wanted
to talk to his fans when you come from
the internet like these publications
it's so stupid like you've built a brand
built a business and built an audience
I'm just like talking directly to your
fans like why are you gonna release a
statement to page six it makes no sense
it makes no sense and it's unfair to
your on-air legs bottlenecking
yeah relationships between ferret and
critters yeah exactly and no more no
more so if anyone's come on the toast
and talked about some of this going on
coming yeah come look we can you talk to
Berkeley dear fans okay Riley anyways
happy for Miley and she does seem really
happy she looks amazing and I I totally
see what she's saying also interesting
factoid about Hotel Transylvania and
Walmart see I love that she dropped two
bombs she's actually very smart because
well now that people are writing up her
statement they're really focusing on the
two more interesting factoid the
headlines are Miley was dropped from
Hotel Transylvania for like and then
they get to the statement but she she
knows how she's changing the narrative
she knows how to make news I thought
that was wildly interesting I wonder
what the Walmart deal was like I Hannah
Montana thing you think at 17 what she's
still Hannah and she wasn't Liam when
she was with Liam they started dating
last song there might have been one more
season left of Hannah Montana think
there's like a tiny bit of Oh probably
like Amber's new or clothing line yeah
yeah probably did Joe Joe see wha Hannah
damage on it
did you see what's the modern to Hannah
Montana which we got it you'd be wearing
it right now yeah yeah you're so vintage
I love work well we have two stories
about Walmart today we have yes now we
do right okay but we have one story
that's also crazy and I almost skipped
right past it was just like a blip on
the radar
Bethenny Frankel says she's married fine
after shocking Real Housewives exit so
Bethenny Frankel uh she posted two
tweeted quote to my NY h wives
housewives go get him
I had to go since I'm the only one that
is actually married that's how crazy
this ride is you are all amazing
beautiful and strong spread your wings
and fly xoxo so I saw this in she got
all of her cast means but then someone
made a good call is she still
technically legally Devorah divorced or
she's still technically married to Jason
Hoppy
are they still separate no like that's
what it could be like I said joke like
I'm not the only one married but she's
not even married oh I don't know then
also a lot of people thought that when
her and Paul went to Italy that they
might have gotten married he's trusting
oh I guess I wonder if if if your
divorce isn't final in one country if
you can get married in another country I
don't know maybe they just did it like
symbolically because they seemed so
happy together but I would really love
some clarification here because as a
Bethenny Stan I just need to know if my
girls marry I guess like we always
about her legal stuff but is she
officially divorced but some of the
stuff that she goes to corporate now is
like custody when she can be divorced
and still be going through custody right
so I have maybe it's just a quick Google
search yeah it's just confusing because
every season there's like a peak in it
like it's gotten bad and then it gets
better so you don't know if it ever
actually came to an end
yeah do okay in 2019 on May 1st her
divorce was still ongoing
oh my god yeah that was so he wants to
know she's still married she was making
a joke no way I can't believe that it's
actually so crazy that none of the Real
Housewives of New York are married yeah
I'm just wait now on Wikipedia it lists
I mean more fake news but it lists that
Jason Hoppy she was divorced from in
2016 and Paul Bern and married 2019
either someone just posted that
overnight or like they know something
that we don't know even look at the
citations yeah yeah yeah source uh where
they sourcing click his name yeah like
the little number I thought it would
just be the most recent one oh no
there's no there's no link there I'm
okay Bethenny Franco reveal secret first
marriage oh no a secret first marriage
that's not it Bethenny Frankel divorcing
Jason Hoppy case settled
she thinks um like just like high five
fan yeah I love the house I'm so
surprised that's like remember when um
people change
amber Valletta 'he's in wikipedia to
medicine parks lettuce and i mean she is
that she's an absolute yes for sure
actually I don't know honestly Rob
bullet I was like the weirdest blip on
reality TV arra TV radar it's like his
mom sister mm-hmm amber is his
half-sister his house sister is like a
worldwide superstar even though I've
never seen her actually working anything
other than revenge for like a minute the
TV show on ABC and he just like came on
TV for a second and then left and now he
just hangs TVs in seven minutes I know
and you know what the more I hang TVs in
my life the more I realize what a real
scale that 7 minutes look I had a full
company come and do it there were like
three guys with all their tools and they
did not do it in seven minutes you hung
yours by yourself now no but like watch
doctor like with the super and it's a
cently doesn't take seven minutes you
know it's and I had like a full fledge
like professional company do it and it
did not take seven minutes crazy I'm
impressed
crazy stuff
okay this and final story is a black man
update from the snitch
she just air-dropped it to me oh but
before we do that can I tell you that
today's episode is also in part brought
to you by Ori yes you can because I love
or 8 and the toasters need to know that
this is a new sponsor you guys if it's
jewelry made in New York it's designed
founded for women by women the pieces
range from classic to statement to
completely original and/or it makes the
jewelry you've always wanted but could
never find their gold feels substantial
and the diamond sparkle and shine
they're very high-quality and really
really beautiful
because it's all real gold you can wear
it and never have to take it off I can't
get anything a cute piece of jewelry
that's like so like fake that you wear
it in the shower and it becomes like
yellow no like white green there's they
sell directly to you without the
middlemen mark up they can offer really
quality pieces but at a fraction of the
cost they have a hack to jewelry market
making wheel Gold's accessible it is
ethically made in New York empowering
women with the best jewellery options
without sacrificing style for every
piece sold the child need receives a
book to further their education I love
buying stuff that makes me feel good
this I don't even feel that about the
price tag to me it's like teaching a
child to read I can't put a price on
that
alright is looking to set the standard
for women because women deserve the best
that is so true we really do deserve the
best okay so here's your here's your
promo for 50% off your first or a
purchase go to or eight new york.com
slash toasts and use the promo code
toast so that's a you are a te new
york.com slash toast you'll get 15% off
if you use the promo code toast at the
link or rate a you are a te new york.com
slash toast sign-on look amazing I like
that to remember the movie bedazzled of
course with Elizabeth Hurley
no actually bedazzled no yeah no and and
Brendan Fraser was it and he has that
click he's like the devil yeah oh yeah
was it called bedazzled yeah it sounds
right oh yeah you're right yeah yeah I
lose Haydee which which I just watched
on Amy and Margaret a hotel room and it
was on yeah with the no that is I think
one of the most underrated rom-coms like
of our generation it's so good and it's
also a classic cuz it's a remake right
and it's just like little Farrell and
Nicole came in like the do I didn't know
I need yeah no no it's so good
can you do that again
it's something like a chip of it please
em I am Samantha yes
okay what's the last name Samantha
bewitched hi once they submit the beat
some other way yeah yeah I don't know
what he did the final story a New York
man has been crushed to death after an L
apartment building elevator malfunction
oh my god Margo told me the story
yesterday and when she was describing
like the gory details to me I almost
threw up it is my worst [ __ ] night oh
my god I've been sick a little too often
in the city a 30-year old software
salesman died when he when the elevator
he was stepping out of dropped without
warning a New York City man was killed
on Thursday morning when an elevator in
a luxury apartment building malfunction
crushing him between the car and the
shaft Sam was trying to exit the
elevator in the lobby of the 23-story
Manhattan promenade tower when this car
suddenly fell on him officials said he
was pronounced dead at the scene legs as
he was exiting the car moved trapping
the patient the fire department told
reporters building surveillance video
team by the New York Post so is it real
I don't know showed another man exit the
elevator just before it malfunctioned
the man tried to pull him hope they're
not releasing the video of the sky I've
seen a lot of videos I just don't know
if it's like a news reporting it oh yeah
they're posting the video okay there are
other atrocity of the week oh my god
that's awful
awful you should not who needs to see
that wait sometimes I don't understand
when you have to release something
really gory because it's like evidence
or like it's like that is awful like
this guy was literally just died for
absolutely no reason and I really wish
that they wouldn't put that up 100%
that's there a second atrocity of the
week and the third which we didn't even
talk about Zayn glazed Ain the New York
Post is getting major [ __ ] because they
ran a picture that appear to look like
Liz a Maxwell who is literally gone
mixing she was missing she was Jeffrey
Epstein's like right-hand woman
attention women madam procure of
children and no one has been able to
find her like they thought she was in
Boston hiding away in some estate and
then apparently like a picture of her
just sitting outside it in and out was
was released and it's like so weird
they're looking for everywhere she's
that [ __ ] in and out that's something
I would do and this picture went viral
and apparently it's completely big and
fraudulent completely think and it her
lawyer like was the one who submitted it
to the press so like New York Post is
messy as hell and I just have to say the
person who posted the photo from the
your post is the same person who wrote
the article about Claudia girl get your
[ __ ] together girl and I think she might
be new like she is not having a good
week of pages no she is not like I can't
I know that they don't I run this
article I mean that video like that
really is upsetting it's deeply
upsetting so this is this is so sad this
man is such a cutie and oh my god what a
what a horrible thing to happen building
yes I'm 25th and 30 hits keeps me aah oh
my god that's so scary about people in
the building are freaking out of course
this is you never been busier of course
Manhattan promenade you know the awning
oh I know exactly it's right next to
where that kosher restaurant promenade
it's a huge building it's like the whole
block yeah oh my god might feel scary or
like when you know the building yeah
because like there and also that just
like I could have lived in that building
it's in a good area yeah doorman
building yeah yeah that's a rental
building I literally could have live
there not safe not to make literally
everything about me I'm sorry no six
other people were on the elevator but no
other injuries were reported
he was the last one to get out which
everyone walked out and literally has
one foot out the door like that
sometimes when things like that happen
it makes me think like that there's
definitely a higher power at play like
there's so many freak stories like I
read the craziest story once this guy
was dancing at his own wedding holding a
beer he's having the time I was like and
he slipped and he fell on the glass and
the glass literally sharded in his like
lung and killed him you know oh wait
this shard I'm sorry the shard like
stabbed I'm sorry I added two words
together I'm really sorry it's not funny
that is such a freak accident like
someone dies at his own wedding because
he slipped like God wanted him he was
here the groom yes I remember reading
that story being like what a horrible
story and this is the same thing
everyone gets and that's it very nice
way to think about it everyone gets out
of the elevator
he's like what if he was one second
faster he would have been alive like
that makes me think this person was
special God wanted him that was just a
freak way like God needed him a Cepheid
to come up with the craziest way yeah oh
just kidding he wasn't the last one to
get out oh I think that there were so
people in the elevator because he was
getting out when it he's out he was in
the middle but it was only on the first
floor so if the elevator dropped in the
first floor to the lower level that's
only one floor so you could be in the
elevator and a drop if he had hurt but I
don't think he would exactly but I think
he was the one he got he got wrong like
those people that place
heist oh my god I can't even I'm gonna
throw up
that is a horrible story that's why
people don't take the elevators and I
always seems like the biermann's are so
crazy like when they do press in New
York the beer mints they bring slippers
with them and they only take the
elevator I mean they only take the
stairs I watched him go to LA which
wasn't so bad because they don't have a
bunch of like high-rise buildings in LA
I feel like some of the work buildings
that I've been in LA only like ten
floors and they have on slippers and
they take their heels off and they walk
the stairs and they won't go to press in
a building like if you came to like when
we were at OHS oh we were only the sixth
floor but like in those high-rise
buildings if you're not like the in the
world traits half of the rock they won't
go to vogue vogue is like 50th floor
yeah [ __ ] that's why they're not in
vogue the World Trade Center has a
hundred floors they whatever interesting
and honestly look I kind of feel that
call if it wasn't so [ __ ] fat and
lazy maybe I would do it too maybe I
don't know I don't think as a person who
lives in New York you could do that like
unless you live on really the first
floor like every single day multiple
times a day taking the stairs like when
there's a perfectly good elevator
multiple in some buildings six elevators
yeah yeah but they live in Atlanta and
they live in a house and I don't think
there are many elevators in Atlanta but
once in a while thing I could take the
stairs yeah so I guess and just another
reason to leave the city no I know this
is really shocking and very devastating
and I really like I don't know I hope it
doesn't have a wife or something um
really sad story like kind of a weird
way to end the week so let's leave it on
a more positive note um I just really
hope everyone like has a great weekend
and just wants to be nice I used to like
hear people be like be nice to each
other I'm like you're so lame but
there's really like so much value and
just being nice no I see here people say
being nice to each other and I'm like
what do you mean I am like I don't
understand why we have to tell people no
I just understand why we always have to
remind people to be nice but I
understand right now and just be nice do
something positive for someone else
clear a list I cleared a bunch a list
yesterday and I just I can't get enough
up fast enough
I did a post in the toaster it's like
two people have dropped their lists and
see if any chaucer's want to donate and
I went back yesterday to check on it it
was due week so as to 1200 links that's
amazing it's too much yeah I believe I
did 10 well we have a lot of lists clear
to clear but post them to the toes today
like let's just make today about
positivity yes yes
while we have so many eyeballs on our
show thanks everyone for tuning in we'll
be posting some
listen we can help the teachers who are
educating the youths and doing the real
important work I'm not just like circle
jerking each other on Twitter I refuse
to be a part of like the cesspool on of
negativity on the Internet like I spend
so much time of my life on the internet
my knee just refused to meet brought
down I do listen to lover and clear list
according to Amy Vee listen to lover and
clear a [ __ ] list we hope you guys
have a great weekend thank you so much
for listening to the morning toast and
thank you for being a toaster yes
everyone we [ __ ] love you we see you
I was like literally scrolling I was
before bed the ad were before the lover
came out was so long and I was going on
Twitter and it sterically laughing and
Ben's like what's wrong I'm like just
some of these responses are hilarious
there was that one did it mean no there
was that one GFI pep show literally just
making me laugh you guys are just like
so well-spoken so funny and you like
always have our backs and we're so it's
grateful but so are you because I know
it doesn't matter but like when you see
like something that you said that like
you thought was brave and like it's but
there's a bunch of likes and retweets
like it just makes you feel more
validate and that's a terrible way to
live it's where we live in you know no
and it's the game we play so if you're
new here welcome to the morning toast
with a little Melanie I'm warning Shelby
go live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube so feel free to
give this video a thumbs up if you're
watching live on youtube feel free to
subscribe you have tons of new content
coming out always if you're a podcaster
and you're listening to this for the
first time from a podcast we are
available everywhere monday through
friday usually around noon one o'clock
iTunes Spotify stitcher literally anyway
I Heart Radio anyway you can listen to
podcasts um if you're new here and you
want even more me the patreon account
wwwp on comm slash morning trust we do
five extra episodes a month for about
nine dollars and it's pretty premium
it's videos it's audio it's podcast it's
gonna be this cool new radio show that
I'm developing it's gonna be really fun
we're doing the most fun episode
tomorrow we are doing reading with us a
la Khloe and Kylie and I'm really
excited to get you guys so much have a
great weekend just like enjoy have fun
it's one of the last weekend's of summer
so just [ __ ] throw your hair down and
get a white cloth let me host to the
Wild Ones
oh good life and the leathers you and I
you